hi how is everyone doing so I want to
start by saying I have some live demos
planned and I don't know that I've ever
done live demos but I've seen live demos
we've all seen live demos or maybe we
haven't seen them so part of me
practicing for this talk today was
actually I felt like I was almost like
on a piano just practicing the
Switchback back and forth to displays so
hopefully there won't be any hiccups
that all my tabs are lined up but then I
couldn't check my email because I was
afraid of like like having an email tab
in there anyways I'm Jackee castle I'm
gonna be sitting down probably for most
this presentation because they're
recording a video in the back and that's
what this microphone is you might have
seen some of this and some the other
rooms and then there's another one on my
back for you all to be able to hear so
agent-based modeling is what and python
is what I'm talking about today a little
bit about myself so I do a lot of work
in the community and I sit on the board
of the Python Software Foundation I'm a
leader in PI ladies International which
I believe is up to over 70 organizations
were really decentralized so and we had
some stats like six months or a year ago
but we need to work on that speaking of
which if you'd like to volunteer because
I don't have time we'd appreciate it I
helped organize a PI data DC and I'm an
organizer for women data science DC I
sit on the board of data community C I
said on the board of the presidential
innovation Fellows Foundation you heard
Kelly Jenn talk earlier today so I was a
former presidential innovation fellow
and and then I also sit on the board of
fight back which you just heard about
during the keynote and I work at Capital
One so that's why it makes it easy to
organize this here and there the host
and sponsor as you know
I'm on the tech fellow team here which
is sort of like a senior engineering
team that goes deep into different areas
of expertise and offers consulting
mentoring and teaching throughout the
company I I'm working at my PhD I'm at a
ten-year plan because I've been working
since 2010 so this is when I started
studying agent-based modeling I have
been working full time at the same time
it's been a blessing and curse I imagine
someday I will look like this so
overview so I will we're gonna the order
this talk is what agent-based modeling
is about and complexity just to give
folks who don't understand it a little
bit of background a background in
agent-based modeling tools a little bit
of overview of the ecosystem so you can
understand what other tools are out
there because some of those tools if you
start to do agent-based modeling might
actually be a good entry way for you to
start using Mesa and I'll highlight that
may says the agent-based modeling tool
that I had written in Python that I'll
be talking about today and then lastly
the future of Mason so what do myself
and the other project maintainer x'
think about as the ecosystem for Mesa um
so to understand ABMS you have to
understand a little bit about complexity
and there's a great book there's at the
end of the slideshow there'll be a list
of readings so you don't have to write
this down because it includes this book
but this next this concept which is
described in these two pictures I took
from complexity in the art of public
policy solving society's problems from
the bottom up and basically the authors
Koli ender and Cooper's probably saying
that wrong describe a situation where
when you complexity is understanding
interconnected systems and in the
interconnected systems are the
interconnected consider the
interconnectedness of the parts versus
the parts themselves the whole is not
to the some so if you look at like the
tropical rainforests if you remove on
the Left if you remove one piece that
system could fall apart as where if you
look at like the groom's suburban garden
on the right if you remove one piece
it's probably not going to fall apart
because it's this orderly system
maintained unless you remove the person
who's maintaining it Bennett fall apart
but it's more of a organized system the
garden on the right is more of an
organized ordered system versus this
sort of natural organic system this is
horribly simplified but this is where
this idea of complexity comes in this is
not a perfect graph but it's basically a
nice way to bring let's say order and
measurement to what appears to be chaos
and defined patterns in that chaos so
let's let's so let's talk a little bit
about agent-based models and an overview
of applications so these are this is a
list of sort of terms you might have
heard related to agent-based modeling
game theory related but in a BMS we want
less than perfectly rational agents
cellular automata is a subset of
agent-based modeling microsimulation
sometimes used in geography to mean ABM
an individual based model is what ABM is
sometimes called in ecology so what is
it ABM s are a computer simulation
consisting of agents individual entities
interacting with one another in order to
study an overall system each one of
those entities have their own rules so
the elements in these all these models
and the models that we talked about
today have these various elements space
agents so spaces like the world that
they exist in agents are the little
entities moving around making decisions
there's a concept of time and then
visualization is a lot of these but not
always required so this is the Conway's
Game of Life is the most sort of
simplified
version of an ABM cells live or die
based on the number of cells around them
these these these rules give rise to
emergent behaviors the emergence
behaviors as it looks like there's this
collective sort of moving away from the
center and these patterns that are
bouncing back and forth this is not
really an AVM the sorry the shapes
aren't ABM the shapes are not agents but
the little blocks themselves so they
look like an agent that collective shape
looks like an agent but it's not here's
another classic model from 1971 and two
versions of it the left is the original
version and the right is a JavaScript
version with happy and sad shapes and
basically this is shelling segregation
model the idea behind shelling
segregation model was that a agent needs
so much of the entities around them to
be happy and if they don't have that
each tick of the time they will pick up
and move to a new location so in the in
the example on the right you see that
that triangle is unhappy but when
another triangle moves in then then the
triangle in the middle becomes happy
so why ABMS ABMS is a cross-discipline
application so I study at George Mason
and there's a variety of people in my
department but you can do evacuation
traffic flows customer flow management
markets is a huge one Stock Exchange did
a study when they change the length of
their time tick and how that would
affect trading patterns and the impact
on the market before they actually
pushed it to the stock market I think
they were going from one eighth of a
second to one sixteenth and so
organizations you know risk so on so
forth diffusion of information and
adoption dynamics
so one of the one of the important
things about a BMS is that it not just
shows you a possibility of solutions but
it shows you the pathway to the
solutions and things that happen along
the way
essentially a BMS can be very chaotic at
times and this allows you to see whether
this was sort of like an easy transition
a chaotic transition so and so forth so
yeah there's there's also these ideas of
you can have path dependency individual
behavior you can have memory so what
what happens when you give your agents
let's say three time ticks of memory
versus five time takes a memory and what
happens when there's a distribution of
memory amongst your agents like some
agents have no memory and other agents
have all the memory because they're just
really good at remembering things and
how does that affect your system
including learning at an adaptation so
you that's where you can bring machine
learning into machine learning and AI
into models as well also agent
interactions can can generate net and
network effects that lead to deviations
from the predicted aggregate behavior
meaning you know you you have an
assumption of what's gonna happen and
there'll be some examples of this later
but it's not exactly what what happens
because people are reacting to those
around them so growing in complexity
types of models this is predator-prey
dynamics in net logo it's a small
ecosystem of wolf and sheep and grass
the sheep eat the grass the grass dies
or you know disappears and then it
rebirths again the wolf eat the sheep
and then the wolf the wolf end up
reproducing so and so forth when you
have too much of one element in the
system the whole system gets thrown off
one of the things dies off and then all
the rest of them die off
and that is from net logo in a more
complex agent-based model this is geo
sim in this the agents are also
collections of agents so if you see the
borders it's more a political
relationship that's interacting with
other political relationships which are
the think of those as like country
borders or city borders and this is
built in repast which is java with a
custom ide this is where it gets a
little bit more complicated doing
geospatial with networks on top of
networks on top of geospatial it's a
simulation of displaced sorry okay this
place people flows in East Africa using
real maps and conflict and Road network
data this this example takes us from the
assimilated worlds that we were looking
at to real-life simulation this is
created in a tool called Mason which is
also open source came out of George
Mason and it's based in Java and then
lastly this one is sort of the most
complex you can get it's a one-to-one
scale model that's being used for
decisions by the CDC of LA its model
from Los Alamos National Lab to look at
infection infectious diseases I'm using
census data clinic locations so on so
forth this is not using a tool this is
from my knowledge hand coded is it oh
okay let's see if this works
if it doesn't then we will skip because
this is where live demos go bad and
that's where it went bad
it's not I lost my mouse
oh there it is okay yeah I think I don't
have volume is there volume on there
okay I will Oh will this one do it maybe
I'm afraid this is just gonna play arson
if it doesn't work I'll just move on oh
my god that's right that's fantastic
we're gonna we're gonna get really
high-tech here okay I might cut this up
early to like a flock of birds in flight
but how how does a group of animals
ourselves for that matter work together
in an organized way when no one's in
charge like termites building
skyscrapers out of mud or fish schooling
to avoid predators
it's called emergent behavior new order
emerging from chaos and you don't just
see it in nature enter the kilowatt a
robot the size of a quarter developed by
engineers at Harvard what's so
interesting about kilobots is that
individually they're pretty dumb they're
designed to be simple a single kilowatt
can do maybe three things respond to
light measure a distance since the
presence of other robots but these are
swarm robots they work together
the kilobots can organize themselves
into shapes sort of like how cells form
into an organ in your body here's how it
works
the kilobots are programmed all at once
as a group using infrared light each
kilobyte gets the same set of
instructions as the net
with just a few lines of programming the
kilobots together can act out complex
natural processes for example I do a
group of identical cells in an embryo
develop into different parts of the body
in nature this is a fairly mysterious
process but with kilobots it can
recreate it see you how they kill about
to start off blue and then start
randomly blinking either red or green
their instructions are really simple
respond to your neighbors match their
color but just with that simple
programming they begin to differentiate
themselves into red and green sections
of the group a lot like cells
differentiating themselves in an embryo
or here they're dispersing based on the
way gas bubbles spread out to fill a
volume here a swarm of fireflies that
start off blinking handling under
ventually begin to flash it music these
kilobots are mimicking the way bacteria
find food that light represents food see
how they're rotating and inching forward
and slowly homing in programmers figured
out how to make the kilowatts do this by
watching bacteria search for fluid in a
petri dish but here's the thing the
researchers were then able to make a
better program they revised the software
they came up with a new more efficient
way of solving the problem and that
opens up our really tantalizing
possibility because our cells can be
programmed to with the right tools you
can actually go in and alter my cells
genetic code it's software with the
right code maybe you could for example
teach white blood cells to track down
and kill bacteria or cancer cells more
efficiently one day instead of us
teaching kilobots to mimic nature they
might teach less better ways of doing
things and then take over the world and
destroy us all
okay that's I love that video it kind of
just really sums it up um so let's go
into your if I go back here okay I need
to close this tab
no I lost my see I knew this is gonna
happen
and there's less back over here
okay open source to do this kind of
thing so this is from Wikipedia there
are 89 tools listed on Wikipedia that do
this there are a lot and so when I got
started a lot of them were Java based
and I was like which one do I use
because I really didn't want to use Java
and not not all of these are open source
the licensing on these are actually
quite interesting there's a lot of it's
free but strings attached which is
usually like an academic free but if
you're a business you have to jump
through extra hoops and so I wondered if
this was one of the reasons why so many
of these libraries existed because maybe
the licensing was so restrictive or is
these one-offs and people weren't
adopting each other's libraries this is
part of my PhD research so maybe I'll
have an answer for you next time so the
three main tools right now our net logo
which is I'm mentioning this because if
you're getting if you're interested in
this it's a great tool to see a bunch of
examples they have a great example
library and it offers a very easy entry
point
Mayson the java one and repast another
java one are the ones that are sort of
dominating the majority of the majority
of models that are built so Mesa the
library that I worked on has two
distinguishing factors one of those one
of those is that it's written in Python
and then the other is that it takes
advantage of browser-based
simulations I won't spend too much time
on this but I did a bunch of research on
what was out there what was a viable
where there folks I could collaborate
with that kind of thing and because I
thought of course there must be
something out there already and it
didn't quite do what I wanted it to do
so then I created my own there are stuff
in the browsers
here's two visualizations of how agent
base and agent script handle the actual
visualization part of the an ant
simulation ants getting food and of
course I listed the one I'm working on
Mesa at the bottom so okay demos of
models this is the fun part going to
okay so when you you can't see that
Mayor displace now you should be able to
see it okay
so right now we have a bunch of examples
inside Mesa and it ships with Mesa and
this one is we have the shelling example
which was the neighborhood one that you
saw and it's really it's a really simple
setup but there are B okay so you have
the the main files are the model that PI
run dot PI and serve it up high so if we
look at the model dot PI small speck
okay
so I mean if you look at the file
organization all all the examples we
created a standard so there would be an
expectation when you hit the examples
that you'd be able to follow any
examples that you submit back we would
expect to be under this sort of
expectation so there's a requirements
file for each of the models and the
requirements file specifically says
specifically list Mesa we are pre 1.0 so
we don't list the we're not listing the
versions yet so basically the
requirements is for everything that you
need in this model you can detach it
while it's in the Mesa project right now
we're going to move the examples to
another repo so they are completely
separate from Mesa itself so if this
project travels on its own for somebody
to run it they would do pip install
Prakash our requirements and then it
would pull down everything it needed to
be able to run it's a little confusing
now because it actually sits in the core
Mesa repo but for a model you basically
have your see if I can make that a
little bigger
your agent class which creates an agent
they have a position agent type because
remember they need to know kind of type
they are to see what their neighbors are
like a step is a term used for a time a
moment in time and so for each step it
takes these actions of looking at the
the neighbors and the grid around them
to say am I happy am I not happy if I'm
unhappy then move to an empty spot or
else add to the percentage of happy so
these agents exist in like a world which
is the model and the world has height
width density the minority population of
Mafi Popat population and also we have
currently built into Mesa three
different types of scheduling which I'll
show you
an example in a second of the importance
of that and also we have a data
collector built in and a batch runner so
you can do parameter sweeps and collect
that data and then analyze that data so
and then there's also the step on the
model but when you look at so if I
launch the a notebook from here in that
particular folder there is a I wish I
could make that smaller does anyone know
can I change the resolution on this
ah thank you that's a little bit better
so you have a little bit about the
background but you can actually run your
model inside of a notebook and and plot
out the results of the model so this
shows this it just shows how many steps
it is so you don't necessarily need the
front-end version of this you can run
everything having to do with the model
especially if you're doing larger
datasets or using larger seeds the you
can run this all in the backend and then
use them on the front-end for either
separate runs or to use as a sort of an
example model it also you can also
generate pandas dataframes on with
respect to the data collector and then
use that to plot out your happi agents
so this is not like so this is not like
the stuff that you shown because the
stuff that you saw with the grid
front-end because that's that's what I'm
about to show you in a second but like I
said this is more if you're doing
analysis within the notebook the batch
runner basically the batch runner does
parameter sweeps in this particular case
it's doing the range of Immokalee one
through eight being that do I want one
neighbor to be like me or eight and then
it runs for a maximum does ten
iterations runs for a maximum of 200
steps and after you do the parameter
sweeps then you can plot out your
results which you've collected in the
data collector so so if you do then to
run the server we've standardized on
doing Python dot run pi which launches a
server and now we have our little tool
the the way this code is set up I'll
in a second for the server side there's
a JavaScript widget for the controls
here's the grid and then there's a chart
that will pop up here with the number of
happy agents I know it's a little
difficult to see and you hit run and
then the agents run you can control the
sort of speed of the the simulation so
on so forth there are some bugs in the
chart and if you look at the code for
this so run call server and the server
is where we have the visualization
elements basically the visualization
elements are listed here the canvas
element which you switch which on the
left and then right underneath it was
that happy element which was the text
which is defined right here just saying
past this text to the front-end and then
you have the happy chart and the happy
chart calls a chart module that's been
added to our to our list a set of tools
so you don't actually have to do
anything on the front end unless you
want to make our friend and better and
then we would appreciate that greatly
but the idea being that there are these
building blocks and that models can be
built with these building blocks and
somebody who's the subject-matter expert
can focus on being a subject matter
expert and not putting together a web
page and but still be able to share it
with somebody else okay great so an
interesting thing to note is so shelling
the shelling example is a really simple
example we basically went through all
the files that generates the analysis
and that generates the the server
display it includes and it launches a
tornado server in the background
something to look at is the wolf sheep
model in the examples and the reason is
it's sort of an example of a complex
model you'll notice the Spile layouts
the same except for everything else is
in the wolf sheep subfolder just to keep
it clean so you know that these are the
components of the model I prefer this
layout even if it's a simple one but
some people like to not have to create
extra directories but yet so if you're
if you're dealing with a more complex
model it's a it's a great one to look at
now so I told you about I told you about
the scheduling thing that we have built
in there's an example example for
prisoner's dilemma and does anyone not
know prisoner's dilemma
okay so prisoner's dilemma basically
says that there are two entities and
they can either cooperate or defect if
they cooperate if they cooperate both of
them get one receive like one point if
they defect they get zero if they both
defect meaning they don't trust the
other person then they they'll both get
zero if one of them cool if they both if
one cooperates and one defects the
person who cooperates gets twice as much
this is probably not a yes so there's
the defection bonus generally set at one
in this in this particular example the
defection bonus is one point six so the
idea is you know do you attack do you uh
part cooperate or do you affect defect
so you know it's kind of a the idea of
prisoner's dilemma is you have to trust
the other person and whether you trust
the other person what is the most
optimal way for you to make your next
decision whether to cooperate or defect
from that relationship and the important
thing about this is that
Mesa has various activation schedules
which includes a sequential random and
simultaneous so this is how they're
activated with each time tic where
agents are activated in the order
sequential agents are activated in the
order they were added to the model
random activation is where they're
activated in a random order and
simultaneous is simulating simulating
them all to be activated simultaneously
which can also affect the outcomes of
the models that you write and this is
really interesting because I'll give you
the TLDR here's sequential activation
here's the results from random
activation and these are all sort of set
with the same starting seed so they're
all they're all coming starting in the
same place and then here's the result of
simultaneous activation and that
completely changes the outcome in in
these examples so if you are using this
this is something very important to be
conscious of when building models and to
take advantage of in your testing
process with respect to activations okay
so just to wrap up here is a Mesa
it's very pretty drawing so everything
we talked about we're models built on
top of Mesa
and then Mesa is underneath it
Mesa itself has the model the
visualization server the the browser web
page the data collector the batch runner
and these slides will be available so
you can look at this later so we talked
about all the models using Mesa
but what the real vision for this is is
to create an ecosystem where models can
be shared so right now we're just going
to push those models up
and right now I'm working on adding
networks to Mesa I have an example we're
not sure yet if that's going to reside
within Mesa or to be a library that
works with Mesa like Mesa networks
that's why it's in kind of this halfsies
geo Mesa would be an external library
not inside Mesa but working externally
with Mesa because geospatial libraries
are heavy lifts and somebody's not using
it you don't want them to have to
install it and networks uses a network X
but then on top of that you can have
stuff like let's say let's say a group
of sneeze subject-matter experts decide
that they want to create norms with the
way they test models and so then they
might create agents and models and a
suite of that that inherit from Mesa but
then other people build on top of it
when they've sort of done research and
say this is the path forward for this
sort of school of thought so that could
lead to something like econ Mesa so B
Mesa it econ makes on top of it and then
people would build other models on top
of that to test under these various
parameters that this subject matter
expert group decided to lay as the
foundation that is not something Mesa
would maintain but it would be for the
subject matter experts to maintain and
own or there could be something like bio
Mesa and the biology people maintain
that or some other school of thought or
discipline I started in 2014 with two
people now there's 26 21
we're from sprints at various
conferences I can't emphasize how great
that was if you are maintaining a
project now we have three core
developers we just invited a new one and
most were not ABM experts a lot of them
were Python experts we've had a lot of
student usage talk to a few government
folks who are interested in using it so
I mentioned some of the to do's in there
one of the important ones is
parallelization of models right now we
are pre 1o so we can still break things
we are not planning on it
we don't intend to but we're not ready
to commit until we get some of these
other sort of major core things out the
door and and to get started and to
contribute there's docs tutorial look in
the examples repo examples now exist in
the main repo so if you do pip install
Mesa you'll have to then clone the
regular repo to get the examples but
those will be moved out soon
also ticket number two to three is
actually standardizing on our package
format and you can translate a model
from net logo things to read and the end